we are with
uh maxine bashir lagrave maxim
we're kind of disgusted because you're
trying to make alejandra look like a
genius
not easy
but this must feel really good to play a
move like e6 and winning such dominating
style
well i mean it was a regime out of time
before uh oh in the game i was not
completely sure with what i did before
but of course when jeffrey took on g4 i
think he just forgot
that i could play rock h1 he should have
gone g6 immediately
and
i thought i was pressing but it's not
completely obvious i thought maybe
i played to direct at this point but it
worked out extremely well it did because
i wanted to play f4 in the engine said
you should play f3
and then you played f45 and then you
said g6
slows you down no i saw g6 of course um
you may bring up that board yeah that
was the
intention because we didn't see it for
you uh yeah my intention was e6 clear
this is what we this is a specific
bishop d4
take bishop d4
wow and no cafe
and this i was not completely sure about
like uh might have changed my mind uh
context g6 context g4 contact g4
we were always looking at an e5 yes and
then i just uh maybe i start with g7
here of g8 bishop e5
and it is a dangerous pawn at least like
i don't think i'm ever worse
in this situation
right
yeah this looks very good for me yeah
what you're
okay so i don't care what you should do
for i don't know
we we got sidetracked with capturing on
g6 and trying for uh
this is actually a very nice tempo and
the difference of course is if we put
the rook on g8 in this case then you go
f6
and you've got great yeah you've got a
great game ah
wait wait because maxime is saying the
engine is an idiot
c5 yeah well why not i wouldn't
i would never say
i would never say the engine is an idiot
well you just said that you don't care
what the engine has to say that's what
you said yeah but that's not saying that
he's an idiot that's okay the engine
can't fight you
c5 with the threat of bishop cc yeah
this is actually quite nice yeah and
rick takes d4 yeah because again i saw
time in time but i might not be in time
yeah bishop if i bishop c6 and then
bishop d6
yeah
yeah like i said uh
i was not completely happy with my
direct play but
um
because i'm slightly better
but i
thought a 455 has a chance to work and
uh
yeah i was that was why i was 100
of course i miss this uh you know now
we're beginning the stupid engine idea
but
now you call it
an idiot yeah you just call it stupid
right yeah but that's out of frustration
yeah yes
you're in first place there's a
mathematical chance of you winning the
entire tour
uh if wesley
drops back
and uh ends up in fifth place in this
event tomorrow is going to be a big game
yeah oh we like the sound of that are
you going to go after him
well uh
i mean probably not like burning all my
bridges because
you know
with my leadership position depending on
how analysis go uh
you know it would also make sense not to
not to go a lot at the risk of losing
but obviously this is a game where i
should pressure him i'm four four four
with white so
yeah you're four for four with white
against him
no in this tournament sorry in this
tournament you're dominating with the
white pieces uh
sec and also second place is looking
pretty nice with chakriar not really
chasing you anymore
yeah i mean i
it's not my bother like i'm trying to
play well
trying to play good games
actually today might be my
my worst game
sort of with this miscalculation but
but at least this way it ended
quite quickly so i have time to to rest
to figure out what to play tomorrow and
come up for a big fight it's nice to
play a worse game and win fast like yeah
yeah well i mean worst game i'm not sure
about horse game but you did lose a game
by the way so yeah but
this is a direct miscalculation
so
you know it's not an easy one by all
means but uh
this is not something that
still should happen i mean when i'm
playing
uh the way i've been playing since the
start of the event did you know that
nobody has won the sing-fil cup after
losing a game
in seven tries everyone went and bitten
yes that's actually amazing
including yourself including yourself of
course
[Laughter]
it yeah be quite an accomplishment uh to
to be a person to win it win this event
and having lost again to make that
comeback
yeah well it's too early to tell but uh
definitely you know i'm going out for it
in the next two games so all right we
look forward to a great play today or
lee's great finish and good luck
tomorrow thank you maurice
congratulations
maxine